NARRATOR: Ken Sims
doesn't do 9 to 5.
[music playing]
This is his idea of a
good day at the office.
For over 20 years, he's
ventured into active volcanoes
across the globe to collect
samples of molten lava.
Studying this stuff is
one of the best ways
to understand what's happening
in the center of the Earth
and the process that
protects us from the sun.
Pretty much that
whole bottom terrace
now is completely covered
in brand-new lava flows.
With the new lava flow coming
around against the wall there,
we'll have to watch out.
The lava's intensely hot,
roughly 2,000 degrees.
It will burn pretty much
anything on contact.
ALDO KANE: OK, heading over.
I'm going over just
towards the edge here.
We'll have a look.
Whoa.
Holy-- it's just opened up
on that site, hasn't it?
KEN SIMS: Yeah, totally.
Whoa.
Nah, Ken, I'm pretty certain
that there is absolutely
no way we are going down there.
That is without doubt
mission impossible.
KEN SIMS: OK, well, we're
canceling this mission.
Just anybody with half a
brain wouldn't go down there.
NARRATOR: The new
vent means Ken can't
take samples from the lake,
but he doesn't need to.
The vent is firing
fresh lava right at him.
KEN SIMS: There's a lot
of lava bombs around here.
It's just covered with bombs.
Wow, I can see the
vent from here.
It's really rocking and rolling.